crazy people have been trying to break
into Joe Rogan's Comedy Club lately and
failing miserably these are some of
those wildest moments caught on camera
starting off with this schizophrenic
streamer who kept telling the security
that Joe sent him this oh I'm sorry I
thought I thought this was a man I'm
with the crew bro I'm with the crew Joe
sent me Joe sent me bro Joe sent me dude
Joe sent me he told me he sent me he
sent me on can't get inside first right
all right well you'll hearing this from
my people then there was a completely
unhinged moment from this dude outside
the Mother Ship before an episode of
kill Tony where he repeatedly shouted
the n-word and smashed a random guitar
I'm ready for kill Tony right now are
you how many minutes you have how many
[Music]
minutes the mother ship is heavily
guarded by loads of X Navy Seals which
is why only